foreign
I know some of you are probably tired
it's like the end of the day but if it
makes it any better I promise the worst
part of today's program is over because
this upcoming part is about beyond the
worst literally it's about Beyond The
Curse beyond the worst case analysis and
specifically it's about instance
optimality in the context of database
query evaluation
was also about another approach to
Beyond versus analysis which is
complexity but then my joke not work as
well
so why do we need Beyond versus analysis
in the context of databases in first
place actually Hong already gave some
reasons and I'm gonna give a few more
reasons
one reason is that worst case
can be too pessimistic in the sense that
the worst case database instance can be
unrealistic
another reason is that worst case
analysis measures the runtime using
input size as a measure however in
databases statically input size is not
even a lower bound on the runtime and
this is because typically in databases
the input is actually indexed and
structured in particular a typical
workflow in databases consists of a
pre-processing stage in which we sort
input relations and build all sorts of
data structures and indices and then
according evaluation stage
in which we reuse the same indices that
we built for many queries over the
lifetime of the database thus amortizing
the cost of the building this data
structure as and and indices and as we
will see in many cases thanks to these
data structures it's possible to
evaluate many queries in sublinear time
now as I mentioned at the beginning
there are many approaches to Beyond
versus analysis this is a highly
incomplete list
[Music]
complexity various query with measures
there is also average case analysis
which might be a new frontier to expand
wears case optimal joint algorithms that
might be a little bit underexplored but
for today's talk we will focus on
instance optimality
in instance optimality there are
basically two main goals that we are
trying uh to achieve
suppose that we have some problem B and
we are given some input instance to that
problem our first goal is the following
our first goal is actually to find a
lower bound F of I on the runtime of any
algorithm on this input instance I
so we are no longer we no longer care
about the input instance length in fact
our Target now to differentiates between
input instances that have the same
length
now assuming that we have somehow found
such a lower bound our next Target is to
design an algorithm X star
whose runtime on every single instance I
is within some ratio M from this lower
bound that we just found and this is a
very strong uh and hard to achieve
notion of optimality these algorithms
can be hard to find the ratio m is
called the instance of humanity ratio
yeah now one gen so where exactly does
this lower bound come from one General
approach to find such a lower bound is
the following now every algorithm that
produces some correct output must
somehow implicitly produce some proof of
output correctness we call this proof
typically the certificate
and the runtime of the algorithm on a
certain input
is basically lower bounded by the size
of the proof that it's produced
implicitly
therefore if we take like a certain
inputs instasfix and input instance and
think of the smallest
proof that you could ever produce for
the output for this particular instance
and this quantity is basically like the
smallest certificate size that we can
found for this particular instance and
now we can use this as a lower bound on
the runtime of any algorithm for this
instance
one of the early actually very
interesting uh
uh applications of instance of humanity
in databases comes from this seminal
paper by Ron Pagan and others which got
the good price
uh the paper was about a very specific
problem the database aggregation problem
which I don't really have enough time
right now to cover in detail however
what I want to explain out of this paper
is basically a meta algorithm a skeleton
that we uh you can think of Fagan's
threshold algorithm as a specific
initialization of this meta algorithm
and over uh
the course of this talk we will also see
a couple of examples that can also be
seen as a special instantiations of this
meta algorithm but this meta algorithm
is not the only way to get an instance
optimal algorithm
algorithm works
basically is to find a certificate or a
proof of correctness that is as small as
possible and we are trying to do this in
a greedy way so we will start by
initializing our certificate our proof
to be empty containing nothing and while
our certificate does not really contain
enough information to group the
correctness of the output we will issue
some carefully designed equality to the
input to extract some new pieces of
information Q about the inputs and we
will add these these extra pieces of
information to our certificate
and it's essential that these every time
we show a query we extract New pieces of
information that did not really overlap
uh with anything that we already know
about the certificate but now none of
this is magical yet
here is where basically the magic takes
place if we can design our queries in
such a way so that every other
certificate
see Brian for the for the same instance
must overlap with at least a ratio a
fixed ratio let's say one over M of the
query output that we just added to our
certificate
if we can't guarantee this then we can
basically show that no matter what our
certificate that we are going to build
at the moment if we compare it to any
other certificate it's going to be no
larger than that certificate by a ratio
of a factor of M
including the optimal certificate so
this is how basically we show that our
certificate is no larger than the
optimal certificate by a factor of M
and you can think of Fagan's algorithm
as basically a special instantiation and
a special application of this particular
argument over here that leads to this
and I'm gonna show you later a couple
more instantiations of this meta
algorithm
any questions so far
yeah so let's start with one of the
simplest sort of database queries which
is set intersection
so let's say we are given two sets of
numbers R and S and we want to compute
their intersection as a database query
this can be written like this
and uh in the various runtime is
basically the minimum of the two sizes
of the sets are
as were basically the assistant.r R and
S are indexed kicks in because we can
always iterate through the smallest one
of the two sets and do lookups in the
other set and if if that's it like is it
stored in a hashable or a B3 we can do
these lookups efficiently
okay yeah yeah or using hash tables we
might do this in order but yeah probably
yeah you are right for the purpose of
this talk I'm gonna be sort of uh
ignoring worry log factors but I will
also be using teldas so yeah you're
right
now
this runtime expression does not really
differentiate between instances that
have the same sizes for R and S so for
example if you if you take a look at
these two instances for set intersection
the first instance could end up being
much easier to detect that the
intersection is emptied in the second
instance and this is because if we are
lucky enough to compare let's say the
largest item in R against the smallest
item in s we might be able to detect
just in constant time that the
intersection here is empty on the other
hand there is here a lot of zigzagging
uh going on
like a formal notion of a certificate
complexity or proof complexity let's say
for to try to differentiate instances
like this that have the same sizes
around this and they still say that this
instance is technically much easier than
this instance
for historical reasons the first sort of
building blocks for an instance optimal
set intersection algorithm or also set
Union were described actually in this
paper uh there's also a series of papers
describing different Notions of
certificates for the problem including
like a form of comparison certificates
and a form of Gap certificates that I'm
gonna
uh explain some form of uh soon by
bourbon Canyon and the notion of
certificates I'm going to actually
present now right now like two Notions
of certificates
thanks to this paper by hunger and
others from pots 14 uh
they are basically called comparison and
GAP certificates but I should emphasize
that they are basically very related to
previously described Notions of
certificates
so here's the thing now if you take an
arbitrary let's say algorithm for set
intersection
of two sets R and S and let's fix uh the
input relation sizes so let's say we
will just instantiate this algorithm for
a set R of two set of two items and the
set s of one item and the set R is
sorted and now
depending on what kind of operations the
algorithm uses like to access the input
we can basically unpack the algorithm
for this particular input length into a
decision tree
where at each node we basically like if
the main operation in the algorithm is
basically comparing input values then
every no every in or not in the decision
tree is basically a comparison depending
on the result we go either left or right
until we finally get the output
now with this picture in mind the worst
case the wears case analysis basically
vertex analysis is concerned with trying
to find a tree that is basically as
shallow as possible trying basically to
compress the height of the tree
but in instance uh like uh optimal
analysis
we are actually concerned with the depth
of a specific Leaf in this tree so if
you take a specific input instance and
uh like uh evaluate it's output using
this decision three you will end up at a
specific leaf now the runtime that
algorithm spends is lower bounded by the
depth of this particular Leaf let's say
if we if this is the leaflet we'll talk
about we took an input instance and we
tracked this sn3 and ended up here then
we know that runtime of the algorithm
must be at least two steps
yeah so I'm taking the intercession of
course process but I just wanted to
emphasize that this set is sorted X1 is
less than X2
oh
these are two arbitrary sets someone
like from the previous slides so the
first one is the second column the
second one is the set yes so this is
basically all
we're only focusing on fixing the input
lens so we're fixing a set of main goal
set of plant one
into a decision tree
yeah so in instances uh optimal analysis
essentially to minimize the depth of a
specific leaf for every single leaf
and moreover like if you take an input
instance let's say on the track business
history and let's say you ended up here
if you track the comparisons that we
performed along the path from the route
down to the leaf the comparisons that we
performed must form a certificate of
correctness that out that the output is
empty so for example if we know that y
less than X1 is false and y greater than
X2 is true then this is already a proof
that this intersection is indeed empty
it must be the case
necessarily the smallest proof because
in this case actually even this alone y
greater than X2 could have been a
sufficient proof so these three uh is
not necessarily in such optimal at least
definitely not for the for instances
that end up here but this is basically
the idea how we can think of algorithms
let's say that are based on comparisons
and now let's focus on the class of
algorithms that only interact with the
input through comparisons of the
following form through comparisons of
the form RI Theta SJ where RI is
basically the ith smallest element in r
yes so so I haven't so what happens
how important is the order here what
happens if your input doesn't have an
order can we impose an order and that
things will work or it is critical that
you know you have some order you can't
predefined order that you use
and then uh like in the worst case you
might you might still be forced to scan
the entire input like if that if the
items are completely non-sorted then it
might be the case that in the worst case
you are still forced to scan every
single one of them to produce another so
you are still overbounded by the input
size
so basically the idea is that we are
trying to utilize indices let's say if
we have like a B3 for the sales so that
we can avoid spending on spending linear
runtime and running in sublinear time
yeah so we will focus on the philosopher
algorithms that basically access the
input only through these comparisons so
the algorithms just emphasize the
algorithm like internally you can do
whatever it wants to do it's just that
the interaction with the input only
takes place through these comparisons so
the algorithm for example is not really
allowed to fetch like a number a value
or out of I it's only allowed to compare
these values to use comparisons of this
form to compare
uh values from two different sets
and
from like the basically the argument
from the previous slide with this
mapping to decision trees we know that
uh the runtime of these uh algorithms is
lower bounded by the sizes of
certificates that we can produce that
only consist of these inequalities
so let me actually give you a quick
example suppose that we are given those
two sets R and S that are shown here
they only intersect uh at the seven and
this is basically one comparison
certificate
and knowing this knowing just this
without knowing anything about the input
or the output we can conclude that this
is indeed the this is the only possible
intersection point between the two sets
okay and here is one way to prove it
based on those two inequalities we know
that S1 to S3 are completely sandwiched
between R1 and R2 so none of these can
possibly be part of the intersection as
for the point right right after that
overlaps with R3 so it must be the first
intersection point and R4 basically does
not exist so indeed if we scan these
inequalities even without knowing
anything about the input we can already
verify that the output is correct so
this is need a valid certificate
now unfortunately designing uh an
optimal an international certificate
whose runtime is directly bounded by the
comparison certificate size might be a
bit hard so instead we will introduce
another notion of certificate uh as a
proxy and then connect the two Notions
of certificates
the other Notions of certificates that
we are going to use is basically
gap-based certificates in particular
we basically want to collect gaps from
each one of the two input relations gaps
between two consecutive items in a
relation
that cover everything that is not in the
intersection so here is a demonstration
on the exact same example
where there is only one outputable which
is seven
now from the relation s we know that uh
there's nothing before too so we can
exclude this region from the output from
the intersection from the relation R we
know that there's nothing strictly
between one and five so we can exclude
this region so as you can see using
those four gaps we can basically prove
that there is nothing in the output
except for seven
and as it turns out it's actually
possible to prove to connect the sizes
of the two Notions of certificates that
we just described so it turns out it's
possible to prove that the Gap
certificate the size of the Gap
certificate plus output size is
basically less than a constant Factor
times the size of the comparison that's
the certificates and the proof that I'm
about to outline basically goes back to
a paper by hunger and others from boss
14 that I mentioned at the beginning so
here is basically a quick overview of
the roof strategy in order to prove
something like this we need to start
from a comparison certificate from a
specific instance and a comparison
certificate and construct the
corresponding uh basically box
certificate and output set
while satisfying basically this relation
in order to do that we'll basically
initialize the certificate and the
output set to be empty and we will keep
looking for a point T that does not fall
within a gap that we already discovered
and any output point that we already
discovered
so let's say we found first uh this
point t
now
because this is an auto point we know
that the comparison certificate must
contain equalities at this point because
if it didn't if there were no equalities
that are forcing those two items to be
identical then we could have we would
have been able to perturb the database
instance so that basically R and S are
no longer overlapping without violating
any comparison here but this is
basically a contradiction because if
this was a valid comparison certificate
it would not have been possible to
change the instance changing the output
of the instance without violating uh the
comparison certificate so we know that
these equalities must exist
therefore we can add this table to Z and
execute the equalities from first from
future consideration
in the other case if T is not in the
output then we know uh uh It Must Fall
within a gap from some input relation
where the two items uh that basically
sandwich uh T cannot really be moved in
the direction of T and why do you know
this is true basically because of the
same reasoning if we could move these in
the direction of T without violating the
comparison certificate then we could
have modified the instance in a way
where we produce an extraordinable here
without validating comparison
certificate but then this means that
this is not a valid certificate in the
first place and it is indeed true in
this instance we do we do have these
constraints on these two points that
prevent them from moving in this
direction
and now basically we can add this graph
to our certificate and continue and we
no longer need to use these inequalities
or at least not in this direction
so this is basically the idea of proving
this notion
and with that in mind here is one
instance optimal algorithm for set
intersection and this is the first
example that I'm going to show from the
meta algorithm that I showed on the
first slide
this is not necessarily the the best way
to describe an optimal algorithm but the
reason I prefer this algorithm for
tourism one is that it fits better with
the metal algorithm and it's also as we
will see later will generalize better to
other types of queries Beyond insert
intersection
this algorithm says we initialize the
Box certificate and the output said to
be empty and we repeatedly look for for
the smallest point that is outside the
the gaps that we discovered so far and
how to tools that we discovered so far
if the point is in the output we add it
to the output
if it is not in the output there must
exist at least one of the two input
relations or both with a gap between two
consecutive items in the relation that
exclude this Tuple to be in the output
we know that there must exist either
this Gap from r or this Gap from s
so what do we do we add both of them to
our certificate
now notice the following think of any
other certificate C brine any other
valid certificate for this database
instance no matter what uh other
certificates Ibrahim has
it must have either one of these two
gaps at least because these are the only
two gaps that are excluding T So for
every other certificate we know that it
has at least this Gap or this Gap
and in our case uh because we don't
really know we added both of them to our
certificate and this is how we know that
if we compare our certificate to any
other certificate it's almost twice the
size and this is how we know that our
certificate is at most twice the size of
the of the optimal certificate
and using the connection that I just
showed to comparison certificates this
is how we prove that this is basically
this algorithm is instance optimal even
with respect to comparison certificates
but maybe I'm missing something here but
why do I need to add those gaps try not
just one of them
yeah if we add only one of them
we use the Ability we basically lose the
ability to make this argument because
now suppose that there is another
certificate uh
might have contained the other gap
but then from those points on it's
really hard to continue inductively with
this uh argument we will lose basically
the comparison like like think of it
this way for example one of those sugars
for example might be much bigger or much
more helpful excluding uh we don't
really know so basically we pay extra
for our lack of knowledge and like your
your definitely have to work with the
wrong fragrance
algorithm so in that algorithm also like
we have like uh M attributes we don't
really know which one of them is going
to lead also the optimal solution We
Gather like items from all of them
simultaneously
but yeah this is probably beyond the
scope of this talk
so with that now we are ready to take uh
this one step further and start looking
into database joins So Hunger already
basically sets the stage for us and
defined the full conjunctive Equity is
basically when I say database runs this
is just another term for full control
conjunctive queries so here is uh one
example which is called the bow tie
query another example this is basically
the Triangular query and the last
example is basically the set
intersection itself that we were just
looking into so now our Target basically
is to generalize those ideas uh to any
kind of query structure
now the first uh thing that we have to
deal with is what do comparison
certificates now even mean anymore what
are we comparing
and the answer might depend on so let's
say now we have an input relation R
which is binary
and the answer might depend on how
exactly the set the relation R is
indexed
for example if it is indexed the on
Affairs and then for every a value we
have an index on B then it is natural to
assume that we can have access for
example let's say to R1 which is like
the first value
of a in R and or we could also we could
also access let's say R11 which
basically means take the first value a
in R and take the first value of B for
that particular value of a and so on so
r21 basically means uh take the second
value of a
uh the first value of the underneath uh
and so on so now we can assume that our
comparison certificates uh
are comparing these values that have the
form enter R1 R2 and so on and now with
this picture in mind let's go back let's
say to the bow tie query where we have
these three relations one binary two
unary and let's say this is the relation
R and let's say it is indexed uh in the
direction a b the relation s on the
other hand let's say it has a three
values corresponding because these
vertical lines because it's urinary on a
uh the regression the let's say has two
values corresponding with two horizontal
lines and now we can generalize the
notion of certificate of comparison
certificates and I'm calling it
specifically a b certificate because I'm
accessing values R1 R1 and let's say of
our that are consistent with this
ordering a b
and this doesn't need a valid
certificate to simplify things like this
part of the certificate proves that the
intersection of a values from R and S uh
is only this point which is uh this line
and this other part of the certificate
basically intersects these tools of r
with T so this is indeed a natural
notion of uh comparison
certification a generalization of what
we did with the set intersection
and similarly we can generalize the
notion of Gap certificates so let's say
now we have the relation R and it is
also indexed in the direction of a and
then B if R is in this is indexed in
this direction then we have uh like a
tall uh rectangle that is excluding any
output tools between every two
consecutive values of a
so we have those sort of rectangles and
for every fixed value of a in R we have
these uh thin rectangles that exclude
the for a given value of a execute
everything between two consecutive
values of B so these are basically the
Gap boxes from r that you get from this
particular index that excludes
everything that is not in r
similarly from s you will basically get
these vertical
rectangles explaining everything that is
not in s and similarly from T and now
what is the notion of uh Gap
certificates
I'm I'm specifically calling it a b
guard certificate because the way we
index R it's basically a subset of all
those boxes
that cover everything that is not in the
output so here the only output Point
here is this point 2.2 uh the two comma
two
uh and it is indeed possible to extract
a set of gearboxes from all the
relations that cover everything but this
point so this is these Gap boxes that we
collected are indeed a valid certificate
once we know them we don't even need to
know the rest of the instance we can
already verify that the only output
point is this
yeah so
basically in this connection between uh
it turns out that the same uh
result that I showed earlier connecting
box certificates to comparison
certificates in the set intersection can
also be generalized to any joining query
assuming that we are restricting the
attribute order so in our example I
reset the attribute order to be a before
B
and this is actually cute result uh is
uh thanks to Hong and others from these
spots for team paper the paper also went
beyond that it introduced the
Minesweeper algorithm which was I think
the first instance optimal join
algorithm among the
other results that it achieves basically
achieves this result which basically
says that we can achieve instance
optimality for comparison certificates
for beta cyclic queries
what is cow oh so go basically is a
global global attribute ordering it
means that if we fix the attribute
ordering uh just like we are fixing a b
here and only consider certificates that
take the comparisons under this ordering
or gaps under this ordering
now for the purpose of this talk I don't
have enough time to go over the one
super algorithm instead I'm gonna
present uh a later framework that we
developed the generalizes uh
uh mine sweeper
in particular under this framework we
generalize the notion
like of box certificates for uh for a
particular attribute ordering and you
basically introduce a tighter notion
where we basically allow unrestricted
guide boxes we no longer care about any
structure for The Gap boxes we just
collect gearboxes from all about
relations we will see what that means
shortly
so now we have uh and under this
framework we have an algorithmetics
which can be viewed as a generalization
of mine sweeper the nice thing about it
is that it works under different kinds
of indexes in order to assume whether
it's a relations index a b or ba it can
be a web Pathways depending on how you
set up the algorithm you can achieve
either uh uh like the fraction hyper 3
which bound that hung covered in the
last tutorial
or if you set the if you set up the
algorithm properly you can achieve a
series of instance of humanity results
which are the ones that we are
interested in mostly interested in this
talk and more importantly actually it
turns out the tetris algorithm along
with the algorithm we also introduce a
roof system for uh full conjunctive
queries
and this roof system can be used to
provide both upper and lower bounds uh
like on the roof complexity
and it turns out you can you can prove
that the runtime of Tetris is always
tied to
like the proof size so technically we no
longer need to analyze the runtime of
Tetris expressly we just need to analyze
groups
so let's take a look about what it means
to deal with multiple indices at the
time let's take the same relation as r
that we were just looking at now if the
relation is indexed in the direction a b
we have these boxes that we can utilize
but it could be the case that we that
our let's say is indexed in two
different directions the same way so it
could be the case that while we are
processing the query we have two indices
for R we can either access it in the
direction of a b or the direction of B A
and the direction of ba gives us other
kinds of uh boxes that we can utilize
it could be the case that R is indexed
let's say inequality which gives us a
completely different uh sets of boxes
but under the new framework
we no longer care we just collect the
Gap boxes from all input relations
and instead we try to solve this box
cover problem on these guide boxes that
we collected the box cover problem is a
simple geometric problem if we have
let's say a universal space a universal
box and a set of boxes that are
contained in this Universal box
our Target is to list all two builds
that are not in the union of any of
those boxes
and it's obvious that we can reduce the
relational joint problem into the box
cover Problem by basically collecting
Gap boxes from all uh the input
relations and solve the associated box
cover problem instead so now we no
longer care about the joint problem and
we now have a geometric problem which is
the box cover problem
and there is an Associated notion of
certificate so given a set of boxes a
certificate for those boxes is basically
a minimal subset of them that cover that
has the same Union
and this this will now become our notion
of uh certificate
so the proof system uh that we introduce
for joins uh is actually before we get
what we need a couple of uh simple
technical tools so we need to use the
the idea of niadic boxes and dietic
intervals
for Simplicity let's say that the domain
of every attribute has a size of two to
the power of D for some constant D so
notice that D is logarithmic uh is Atmos
algorithmic in the size of uh the
database
so
we will basically establish a mapping
between uh so between so let's say this
is basically the full
domain of the attribute we will
establish a mapping of some of the
intervals in this domain and binary
strings of length less than or equal to
D such that let's say the full domain of
this attribute is represented by Lambda
the interest ring zero represents the
first half one represents the other half
zero zero represents the first half of
zero zero one represents the second half
of 0 and so on until depth D which is
again logarithmic in the size of the
database
intervals are all these intervals that
correspond to Strings so this is zero
this is zero one for example this
is not uh a dialectic interval because
it's not a single string
and now simultaneously now we can
introduce a concept of dyadic boxes
uh it's basically a box where if you
project it on every single Dimension you
will get a direct interval so for
example and dialectic boxes can be
represented as two rules of strings in
the same way so for example this box
over here is the total of strings Lambda
1 1 because on the x-axis it's basically
corresponds to Lambda on the y-axis it
corresponds to 1 1.
and now we will be interested in these
diuretic boxes instead it turns out that
dialectic boxes have a couple of
interesting properties that are very
convenient when designing uh uh like
algorithms and group systems
one such property is that every box can
be decomposed into a body logarithmic
number of diuretic boxes
so remember here the D is the
logarithmic and N is the number of
variables which is uh constant in data
complexity so this is just a body
working Factor so for example if we have
this relation over here which has only
distributable and those two boxes we can
replace them with diadic boxes and in
this example we only paid an extra
factor of two so instead of having two
boxes we had to deal with four in
general we will only lose a body
logarithmic Factor if we do this so we
can always switch to the other boxes uh
at a bounded the loss if you are willing
to sacrifice for reversion factor and
also
another nice property that these direct
boxes have is that every point if you
take if you take let's say a unit square
is contained in at most a body
logarithmic number uh of dialectic boxes
like in one dimension in in one
dimension let's say if you take this
unit interval it can only be contained
in like all intervals that are prefixes
of the string zero one
and uh in multiple Dimensions you
basically just generalize this so this
is basically where uh this fact uh comes
from
and now we are ready to introduce our
group system for the box cover Problem
by group system we mean the following we
mean we want to take two boxes two Gap
boxes and infer a new box that is
covered by their Union
and here is the basically the only proof
step that we need it turns out that if
we take any two adjacent boxes
diatic boxes if they are adjacent let's
say along the
uh y Dimension and overlapping in the X
Dimension you can always infer this box
which is their Union in the Y Dimension
and their intersection in the X
Dimension if you want to see how this
looks like in strings so this uh
uh this is basically the representation
of uh the selling resolution of this
rectangle this is the single extension
of this rectangle and uh to be able to
resolve them we must be able to find a
dimension where they are adjacent so in
this Dimension uh they basically have
the same prefix zero but they differ in
the last bit so we can basically resolve
away the one and zero into zero and in
the other dimensions we basically have
to take the longer uh
prefix one of them has to be prefix of
the other in order for them to overlap
so we take the longer prefix
and this is this is basically the only
roof step that we ever need to infer new
boxes of out of existing boxes why do we
call this resolution it turns out that
you can think of this as a
generalization of resolution in logic
here is how we can do this think of the
Boolean Cube and take let's say this
clause
the Clause itself is not really a box in
the Boolean Cube but it's negation is a
box in the Boolean Cube
and if you take let's say another Clause
that resolve this Clause the negation of
this Clause is also a box in the Boolean
Cube and if you take their logical
resolution you get this Clause whose
negation is basically this box
so this is actually indeed this process
is indeed a generalization of
traditional resolution in logic which is
why we call it a geometric resolution
and it turns out this is already a
complete proof system in the following
sense given a set of boxes let's say a
telegraphic a.cover some Target box D we
can always apply geometric resolution on
boxes from a to infer a new box be brine
that covers the
there is no guarantee that we're able to
infer B itself but there is always a
guarantee that we will infer something
bigger that contains B so it turns out
that you can show that geometric
resolution is a complete proof system in
this sense
and there are multiple flavors of
resolution
geometric ordered or and the tree order
the geometric resolution is basically
unreciated resolution we just find as I
mentioned where the two boxes are
adjacent the in circular rotation it
means that they should have the same
prefix but differ in the last bit and
applying resolution on this Dimension
means it's basically removing velocity
resolving the zero and one into a star
basically removing the character but
they also have to be like overlapping
in every other dimension and because
they are diodic intervals the only
possibility for two diabetic intervals
over lab is for one of them to contain
the other they cannot be like neither
one of them contains the other this can
happen in an arbitrary intervals but not
for that intervals and we have to take
their intersection
on every other dimension so we take the
Union in one dimension the intersection
on all the other dimensions
in order geometric resolution we
restrict this roof system a little bit
so that we only allow a blind resolution
on the last Dimension that we haven't
applied resolution on before or like
basically in order to apply resolution
on this Dimension we have to make sure
that we everything else is lambdas the
Box spans uh all the other dimensions
this will basically restrict the
resolution to apply uh one attribute at
a time from the end uh till the
beginning so it's basically a
restriction on our freedom to apply
geometric resolution
and the double cast form of resolution
that we also introduce for technical
reasons is basically three or the
geometric resolution the only difference
is that now the proof we also research
it further to be a tree
in the previous cases that the proof
basically was a dug in the sense that
once we infer a box we could use it in
multiple places but now because the
proof is a three every time we have to
use this box again that we just inferred
We have basically to repeat the entire
uh process to infer it again so there is
basically no notion of caching under
this weak notion of the resolution
it's also like probably people from the
third Community are probably already
familiar like with the three resolution
proofs versus Doug resolution proofs
and now we are ready to describe the
basic Tetris
algorithm which we are going to use
later to achieve the multiple kinds of
bounds
the address algorithm is basically a
recursive algorithm for the box cover
problem it recursively tries to answer
the this question suppose that we have a
set of
boxes a and a Target box D we are trying
to answer whether uh the union of all
these boxes in a cover B
and not only that we are not just trying
to answer this question we are trying to
prove it in the sense that the algorithm
is supposed to if this is indeed true
then the algorithm is supposed to apply
a resolution to produce a resolution
based Groove to infer a new box B Prime
that contains B that can be inferred
from a
so the algorithm is trying to answer
this question and if the answer is
positive we are also trying to apply a
resolution to to actually move it
produce a resolution based proof and
here's how the algorithm works
we split B in half
in either direction so this direction
will come back later to how it affects
the runtime and we recursively apply the
algorithm on each half if we apply the
algorithm recursively on each half the
algorithm let's say if the box is
covered then we will get back a witness
that was inferred through the resolution
that covers the first half another
witness that covers the second half
and now the algorithm applies the
resolution of the two witnesses to infer
a witness that covers B and now we cache
uh that weakness
so this is basically the basic algorithm
I'm going to show like a clearer example
shortly it turns out that you can always
prove that the runtime of this algorithm
is proportional to the number of
resolutions that it performed and it's
actually a very nice property because we
technically we no longer need to care
about what the algorithm is doing all we
have to care about is analyze the
resulting resolution proof and this
rebound runtime
and the how we choose to to split uh
like a box whether it's let's say in our
example vertically or horizontally it
will affect will affect after all the
number of resolutions that we perform
and also the runtime by extension so we
have to select this uh carefully and it
turns out
front ways
different kind
of bounds
the simplest way to use this algorithm
is basically the trivial way to
basically allow the algorithm like
unlimited access to all the Gap boxes
from all the relations
and we call this initialization Tetris
preloaded and using this initialization
we will be able to achieve the fraction
Liberty which bound as we will see
shortly
but now the the initialization of the
algorithm that achieves instance
optimality
which we call Tetris reloaded actually
works in the opposite way where we
instead of allowing the algorithm and
unlimited access to all the boxes up
front we don't we hide basically
information from the algorithm and only
feed the algorithm like information or
boxes on any basis
and there is also another more advanced
version of this that we probably don't
have really have the time to go apart so
let's start with the first
initialization the very simplest one
let's take a clearer example
so now let's say we have this instance
of the box cover problem we are giving
these input boxes and our Target is to
list all output points that are not
covered by these boxes in our case there
is only this
output point so let's see how the the
centers algorithm basically works on
this example
just to clarify so you don't put just to
let's see the uh
yes yes we will do both simultaneously
right now okay yeah
yeah uh yeah so the algorithm
really repeat the question
yeah yeah so that's the dance point was
that basically the algorithm is not
sufficient for the algorithm that
actually basically to report the output
which is this Square in this case we
also want to produce uh geometric
resolution roof
there's no other there's no other
opportunity except for this one so we
want to do both at the same time
algorithm works
we start from the global box that covers
everything and we ask is it already
covered by the import boxes do we
already have a gapbox.cover it the
answer here is no because no we have to
split it and here basically we can
either split it vertically or
horizontally let's say we now fix a
dimension ordering of X before y so we
will always split X before y if we do it
the other way around they will
potentially get a different proof we
will get the same output or we will get
a different proof
so let's say we split it now and one now
we recurs on the first
half and now we ask is it covered this
will have is already covered yes we
already have a witness so we can return
it directly now is this have covered no
we have to split it again along the
x-axis
is it covered no we split again this is
now covered and now we have a weakness
now we backtrack uh it's discovered no
we split is discovered no but there is
no box that covered in the input so now
we can report it as an output and we
also have to add a box
to cover this Gap
and now we backtrack to the other Branch
it discovered yes we have this box that
cover it and now we backtrack
and now we have basically two witnesses
uh this witness covers this half this
witness covers this half so now we apply
resolution
to infer this box that covers this and
now we backtrack one more time
uh we have this box that we just
inferred it covers this half this box
covers this half and now we apply
resolution to infer this and we continue
and if we keep doing this uh
in the basically we will be able to
infer a box that covers everything while
simultaneously producing the output
now this symbol algorithm
it turns out the decimal algorithm if
you choose the variable order carefully
you will already achieve the fraction
however through its plus output size
bound that hung mentioned in the
previous tutorial
and this already implies that it runs in
uh n plus output size uh for acyclic
requires because for a secret whereas
the
uh the fraction number three with uh is
one and it this already implies that it
yes you promised us you're going to show
us an instance optimal not a workplace
optimal so what is the story yeah yeah
so this is one initialization of Tetris
I'm going to so basically the results
that you're asking about are here I'm
going to show I'm going to show them in
the next slide
but in some sense this gives us uh like
some perspective in the sense that uh
basically the point that I probably did
not do a very good job explaining is
that it's basically the same framework
we initialize it in a certain way if we
for example allow the algorithm
unlimited access to the input what will
happen is that we are basically
overwhelming the algorithm with
information but it will still be able to
achieve basically
worst case bounce uh on the other hand
we can try to use the algorithm in a
completely different way where we uh
like hide information from the algorithm
and only give it the minimal amounts
that it needs and this will actually
allow us to achieve instance optimal
bounce so I just wanted to
I tried basically to
explain this one that I probably did not
really do a good job explaining it
uh yeah so this diagram which I'm going
to use to explain uh the results shortly
on this side we have lower bounds on
this side we have basically the upper
bounds the positive results and the
three layers that we see are basically
the different types of resolution that
we have uh the bottom one is the is the
weakest one the most restricted form of
resolution the more restriction we have
on the roof structure the bigger the
roof can get
uh this one is the order geometric
resolution the the top layer is the
completely unreciated geometric
resolution
now what kind of a proof system does
this algorithm do the way I described it
the way I described it this algorithm is
doing order geometric resolution which
lives in this layer and the reason is
that as I mentioned in the river slide
we had to fix an attribute order I chose
X before Y and I stuck with it
uh it turns out that even if you weaken
the algorithm to disable caching
if we don't allow the algorithm to store
boxes if we force the algorithm if we
offer the algorithm no extra memory so
that whenever it infers a box it will
have to reinfer it again if it has to
use it again then it turns out that the
algorithm still basically achieves the
AGM bound
then we are no longer using all the
geometric resolution we are now
demoted the three order geometric
resolution
so it's a bit interesting that basically
if you disable D caching
[Music]
Gallery around actually the AGM bound
if you enable caching on top of it or
dynamic programming you'll get the
fractionality with bound
but in any case this is none of this is
basically a part uh that basically was
the main topic of the talk the part that
we wanted basically to get to is
basically instance of human results that
are measured in the certificate size it
turns out to get instant results you
read another initialization another way
to initialize this algorithm and the
algorithm that I have over here is
exactly another example of the meta
algorithm that I showed at the very
beginning where Ron Fagan's Thrift
algorithm was also one of the examples
so now we are going to use the same
filters algorithm but in a different
setup that will allow us to achieve
certificate size bounds and for that we
will still fix a dimension ordering
but we will initialize the certificate
to be empty because our Target
eventually is to keep this certificate
as small as possible so we'll introduce
it to be empty and as long as the
certificate does not have enough
information we will load a little bit
more information at the time
so we initialize it to be empty and we
run the data's algorithm as usual but
without any access to any boxes
until it finds a point B that is not
covered by any box which initially it
will definitely do because we didn't
load any boxes now if this point uh B
that the algorithm has found is covered
by boxes from the input relation from
the input relations that the algorithm
does not really know about yet then we
load all those boxes into our
certificate
and we repeat this process
and the trick is that remember that we
are dealing with the iodic boxes here so
for every point there is at most a body
logarithmic number of diuretic boxes
that we that contain it so here in this
state in this stage we know that for
every point we will Atmos load the like
a bologographic number of boxes moreover
if you think of any other certificate
any other valid certificate guidebox
certificate
those boxes are the only ones that rule
out the point B so therefore this
certificate must contain at least one of
those body logged boxes that we added
and this is how we know that for uh no
matter what other certificates we
compare our certificate against our
certificate is never going to be larger
by more than a body lock factor from
that certificate and this is basically
how we prove
that our certificate is at most volumic
away from the optimal certificate so if
you replace Ibrahim with the c star this
is basically how we know
and this is another initialization of
the meta algorithm that I mentioned at
the beginning and another usage of the
argument that I mentioned at the very
beginning
so if we use this version of Tetris what
are the bounds that we can achieve now
instead
in terms of that for queries of a tree
with one now we can basically run in
instance optimal time with respect to
this certificate which as mentioned
earlier uh already subsums comparison
based certificates
so this is indeed the like a strong
optimality results but it only applies
to queries of three with one for queries
of uh three width for arbitrary three
width instead we will get uh uh we will
achieve this runtime instead which is a
difficult size the rest of the three
with plus one
another question is uh how good is this
down since this is now no longer in the
softimal but it's away from
accessibility by some exponents it turns
out for this roof system which is order
geometric resolution which the algorithm
uses
there is always there is always a
wireless case instance where the group
size can be actually this big so this
actually proves that as long as you are
only using this group system
there are always instances whose proof
is at least this big and this is why you
we this is how we know that you cannot
really improve this result if you want
to stick with this form of restriction
on the resolution
and the same thing actually it turns out
that for a query with n variables we
know that there is always a lower bound
instance within this order geometric
resolution
as big as this
but now there is a natural question to
ask is now what happens if we drop all
the restrictions and use the most
General geometric resolution
it turns out that there is still a lower
bound but the lower above Now is better
it turns out that it is possible there
is actually a lower bound like a set of
certificates where the the smallest
possible unrestricted geometric
resolution proof is still as big as
significant size there is above n over
two
and uh this lower band actually turns
out to come from a query that is an end
click query
and for comparison the AGM bound that
hungry presented earlier uh for a query
of n variables uh the Asian model is
Into The War of uh of n over 2. so this
bound uh seems to mirror that but now
the question is is there an algorithm
that can solve
uh an instance optimal algorithm that
cannot uh it's technically because of
this exponent but uh is there an
algorithm that at least meet this Bound
for any query and it turns out that
there is indeed a variant of the
algorithm I just described we call it
Tetris balance it does indeed achieve
this Bound for any query not necessarily
a click but what this lower bound shows
us that in some sense the clicker
queries remain like the hardest queries
algorithm is probably beyond the scope
of what I can describe now but it's a
it's basically a space transformation we
still apply the same algorithm but in a
new space that has higher dimensions
and now basically the most interesting
part of the talk so everything was until
now was about the past but now the open
problems are about uh the future the
first open problem that bugs me about
this line of research is can we produce
an algorithm whose runtime is directly
proportional to the geometric Resolution
Group size
now what we just saw from the lower and
upper ones that we I just described the
move size depending on the instance it
can be anywhere from certificate size to
certificate size number two
however if our algorithm runs in this
time like in the various case it's still
not going to be better than Tetris
balance it's not going to be better than
this but at the same way it could be
better depending on the instance because
there are many instances where the roofs
are much smaller than this so this is
now another level of sensitivity now we
are sensitive to the proof size itself
and this actually might resonate well
with like the set solving Community
because in such solving people also like
try to Target the let's say the mini the
smallest resolution three can we find
the Assad solving algorithm whose
runtime let's say is polynomial not in
the input but in the size of the
smallest let's say resolution proof 3 or
resolution proof dug
so this is basically the first question
it's not it's not really clear to me how
we can like construct a
a strategy to get such an algorithm but
this is the one interesting question
another like practical more pragmatic
question regarding uh the application of
the algorithm is basically is there a
way to get rid of the diabetic encoding
this diuretic encoding introduce a big
body logarithmic factor into the runtime
of the algorithm which makes it
impractical if we could get rid of that
then we might be able to benefit a lot
more from this framework
in practice
now the other question is all what I
described areas was just one way to
model instance optimality for full
conjunctive queries so the question is
are there actually other ways there are
probably definitely like other ways uh
potentially better ways to model the
problem
and now
the other uh interesting over the
question for the same queries for let's
say full conjunctive queries there are
algebraic algorithms that are not
bounded by the lower bound of geometric
because the of a geometric resolution so
there are algebraic algorithms that can
basically break this Bond we already
know about this so there is the this
algorithm by Marina Williams and others
which everybody shows that you can
actually break the bound so this one
says it says basically that for a
triangle uh a geometric resolution based
algorithm is going to break uh respond
and when I say your water resolution
based algorithms are also um I'm
subsuming comparison based algorithms
so they can't really break certificates
are just about reservoir of three over
two but we know that there are
algorithms that are actually kind of
break this Bound in the workers can be
and itself
yeah so so the question now is is there
a natural notion of certificates that we
can apply it with these algorithms that
use first matrix multiplication
now all these in all these open problems
we are still looking at the exact same
problem which is full conjunctive
queries even here so here I'm talking
about algebraic algorithms but the query
itself is not algebraic it's just a full
converter query
but now in the second set of open
problems that we have now we are looking
at different problem setups all together
so the first kind of a problem problem
set up that we now want to try to extend
this uh instance of humanity techniques
into is now what if we have uh count or
aggregated queries what is the natural
notion like of certificate how can we
verify when when accounting query let's
say is nine what what do we mean now by
having a proof that account is nine
without explicitly listing
and in the same way what is what would
be like a necessary algorithm in
this notion
now the other also problem set up that
we can try to extend into it's basically
recursive queries
can we talk about uh for example
instance optimal transfer closure or
let's say instance optimal altairs
shortest path
and the last uh basically Broad and
setup that comes to mind is how exactly
does instant personality play with the
online algorithms or how does it work
under updates like in databases we deal
with implemented a view maintenance
where we have uh updates coming to input
relations
so now can we really incrementally
maintain let's say an instance optimal
algorithm and what exactly does that
notion actually mean
yeah so you made it through the day
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
comparisons where they have the big
boxes so are their practical motivations
to constraint the operations
like why would I care to only use
comparisons
yeah like companies has uh have been
used naturally for example to construct
lower bounds
sorting
yeah like uh technically there is no
reception like I mentioned but on the
right on the last slide you could
imagine algorithms that don't really
fall Within that category so it's not
entirely clear like uh how comprehensive
this class of algorithms is my suspicion
is that uh geometric certificates uh
uh subsume combinatorial algorithms but
this is probably just an intuition it's
very hard to extremely quantify that uh
notion
and so is there any longitudinal cost of
technical certificate or are they only
hope you just run it and here
so basically what we found out
groups the certificate could be much
bigger than the certificate itself right
like a compare this for example to the
search Problem the set in the
certificate problem let's say if I give
you an unsatisfiable instance so what
does it mean to have a certificate a
certificate is basically a minimum
subset of the clauses and that is
unsatisfiable
but now that doesn't mean that you can
group it this fast now you need to
construct a resolution or some other
technique to prove it uh but now this
could be a lot more expensive
than the
closest themselves
any more questions
yes please I'm curious uh if this
geometric resolution has any connections
to communication complexity
some of the techniques of trying to you
know starting with some sort of like
Matrix with binary strings on either
side and trying to decompose uh
decompose into some
known shape scene like similar I'm not
sure like but something that people have
problem yeah that's that's such an
interesting question I haven't really
thought about it
but we should probably like the when we
try to
catch up later on that thread to see if
there's something
but we can also formalize this notion
we don't really try to make this
connection
between what communication complexity
versus this is geometric resolution roof
complexity
instead of optimal algorithm so uh if I
should take think about the triangle
query but generic joint is very simple
and confusing
what's with an instance optimal
algorithm
yeah so if we run in certificate size
rest number of three over two
but the problem is that there is a head
embodied working Factor
so the in theory the certificate size
the geometric certificate science could
be much smaller than n
but at the same time there is a very
vertical factor that is demotivating in
practice so the circuit is a tool for
all the missing parameters
yeah so think of it this way if you have
like the Triangular query from every
input relation you will extract uh so
let's say if you take an immigration or
a B uh yeah and the last Dimension is C
now you need to extract like some boxes
from r that cover everything that is not
in R and you need to extend them along
the C dimension
and we need to do the same thing from
every single relation out of the three
relations and now you have like a
collection of uh guard boxes that cover
the entire space except for the
triangles themselves
now these the guard boxes that you need
to extract could be Malaysia much
smaller much uh fewer than the number of
inputables in the relations
yes so in the time complexity oh so it
could be precise uh that time complexity
is uh
more than just a very output
your genetic joint just gives you the
triangles it doesn't give you
this is
also provides objectification
inbounds
now technically you can move status as
uh like status can also achieve the HD
imbalance but the only difference is
that it also produces a proof
if you care about the roof
any more questions
I guess
so so getting back to my early question
about order so suppose I I give you
something that has no order and then I
impose some kind of ordering
and then I run this algorithm
so do I have any chance of getting
something that's better than just the
worst cases I'm talking about algorithm
you need to bring index the input
relations in order to be able to run a
generic drawing yeah but you don't need
order right you can have a house or you
can or it doesn't really matter what all
you have you can impose any order
actually for a versus optimal joins you
you do need like assorted order like a
B3 because we need we actually need to
be able to perform intersection on every
variable in time which is a promotion at
the minimum size so you can use the has
and not be able to do that right so in
some sense the story is not necessary
because you could instead of doing that
you could construct how stables and then
yeah
to be fair yeah a sort of thing is not
necessary we still need a try in the
sense that we need to to iterate over or
count the number of values for the first
variable and then for every value of
that variable we need to count uh number
of values for the second uh variable
but for example why I'm saying that is
you could you could imagine that they
have no order but then it's okay I'm
going to impose this order
and maybe if you do that then different
orders will give give different behavior
of this algorithm right so that's what
I'm trying to understand yeah yeah like
there is a little bit of a philosophical
question like because eventually so here
I was talking about the input by itself
is a set of numbers or every value is a
number yeah but what if the values are
just like uh entities or something now
what does it mean to order the domain in
somebody in order to make sense of
geometric certificates you need to sort
of establish some geometric meaning of
your space you need to import some
ordering but then so this ordering by
itself uh is going to make uh like a big
difference on the size of the geometric
certificate it's longer even clearer
like whether one ordering is more
meaningful than another there are
actually some there is actually a
follow-up paper on terrorist that
examines that aspect like from a
practical Board of view
is that like if you have like an
unordered domain or an order domain that
we wish to reorder in a way that is more
friendly to geometric uh certificates in
fact like one example that I showed the
uh the very beginning for set
intersection
um
look at this example in instance 2 is
not necessarily harder than instas money
depends on how you look at it so for
example if you
think of if you reverse the roles of the
most significant bits and the higher
significant bits in RNs beta2 is not
only become isomorphic they become as
easy as one another
domain
which is not only
practice if you apply a hash function a
random hash function and that gives the
numerical values for these types of
things you haven't ordered
so if you have these two sets that are
whose intersection list is empty and I
apply a random hash function to each of
them
what is the most likely
um in the living
the second one yeah exactly in fact I
think there is an information theoretic
argument that basically you can make an
information theoretic argument to say
that if you generate uh like the
certificate by by selecting a random
order then by information about the
government can't be lower than the input
size because you that's how much
information you need
yes that might have a very very
practical questions so in case in case
of worse case optimal during algorithms
you know we have implementations and
they were shown to perform at least on
some
data scenarios better than the classical
joint algorithms are there any
implementations for instance optimal
joint algorithms that perform better
they have the let's say generic joint
that the worst case optimogen algorithms
yeah there are there were actually a
couple of
attempts but they were not really very
successful in practice because of the
body log Factor so we haven't been able
to show that like from a practical point
of view but this is uh of course one of
the open problems that you are all
invited to try to tackle let me just
point out something I learned three
minutes ago
you learn more than what your voice is
optimal algorithmeter they also returned
the proof that everything not before
that is
eternal proof of completeness
but the truth is every correct algorithm
even if it doesn't determine the group
explicitly it must internally build it
somehow implicitly
n
otherwise it would have been wrong
because
it's like Amazon they would like to
offer his activities that their
Publications
is to provide
what it is
okay so I think valve wants to go home
[Applause]
we are going to hear from you